really i would like to reiterate what we
said last week
brazil condemns in the strongest
possible terms
the use or threat of use of all weapons
of mass destruction including biological
and chemical weapons
anywhere by anyone under any
circumstances i thank you mr president
of brazil for his statement and give the
floor to the representative of kenya
thank you mr president we join others in
expressing our deepest condolences to
the mission of ireland and the family of
ambassador jim kelly over his shocking
demise
i thank miss izumi nakamitsu under
secretary general and high
representative of disarmament affairs
for her briefing
mr president it is it regrettable that
the armed conflict in ukraine rages on
at an intolerable cost to the people of
ukraine and increasingly to the entire
world especially the global south as
prices of essential commodities rise
sharply because of shortages and the
impacts of sanctions
we are gravely concerned by the
sustained targeting of civilians and
objects indispensable to the survival of
the civilian population including
residential homes health facilities
shelters as well as power and water
infrastructure in violation of
international law and international
humanitarian law
at this point mr president this council
should be focused on getting a cessation
of the military campaign in ukraine
we appeal to the concern to do so
immediately to allow humanitarian action
and facilitate a much needed dialogue
towards a sustainable political solution
any allegation of the development of
biological weapons in contravention of
the convention on the prohibition of the
development
production and stockpiling of biological
weapons must not be taken lightly
we call on all state parties to the
convention to make use of the
established mechanisms so that any
concern or suspicion of the presence of
these extremely dangerous weapons can be
verified
in situations of armed conflict we must
point out that such verifications demand
a cessation of the conflict for it to be
carried out
we urge state parties to the convention
on the prohibition of the development
production and stockpiling of biological
weapons to seize the opportunity of the
ninth review conference later this year
to strengthen the biological weapons
regime
in closing mr president kenya reaffirmed
its recognition of the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine i thank
you
thank you president
let me also express our deepest
condolences to the irish mission for the
very sad passing our dear colleague
jim kelly
at the outset thanks to the high
representative nakamitsu for your
briefing
we were called here today at the request
of the russian delegation to again
discuss claims of a
biological weapons program in ukraine
yet we heard from the high
representative last week and it was
repeated today and i quote the united
nations is not aware of any biological
weapon programs in ukraine
russia has failed to offer any credible
evidence for its claims providing us
instead with unsubstantiated information
allegation and interpretations
we have trouble understanding the
rationale behind the last minutes call
to have further discussions today
we find it unacceptable that russia
continues to repeat its unsupported
claims that ukraine is preparing to use
biological weapons
it is becoming quite clear that this is
just another smokescreen tactic to draw
attention away from russia's role as
aggressor in this illegal invasion of
ukraine
president
norway remains a firm supporter of the
biola biological weapons convention and
we are determined together with
parameters in the international
community
together with partners international
community to uphold a total ban against
biological weapons
norway can condemns any use of such
weapons
they cannot and must not be used under
any circumstances
this would constitute a clear violation
of international law
we deeply regret that russia by calling
these meetings seeks to undermine this
council and its vital role to peace
diplomacy
exactly eight years ago we were shocked
by the russian illegal annexation of
crimea
i know
russia is waging an unlawful war against
another u.n member state with
devastating humanitarian consequences
the sole responsibility for the war
falls on russia
russia must end it now thank you
[Music]
since
foreign
negotiations
i give the floor to the representative
of india
thank you mr president
our deepest condolences to the family of
ambassadors jim kelly and members of the
irish
mission i thank usg nakamitsu for our
briefing we have carefully noted the
points made by usg regarding biological
activities relating to ukraine
india attaches high importance to the
biological and toxin weapons convention
as a key global and non-discriminatory
disarmament convention prohibiting an
entire category of weapons of mass
destruction
it is important to ensure full and
effective implementation of the btwc
in letter and spirit
we also believe that any matter relating
to obligations under the convention
should be addressed as per the
provisions of the convention and through
consultations and cooperation between
the parties concerned
as outlined yesterday india remains
deeply concerned at the progressively
deteriorating situation in ukraine
we welcome the latest round of
diplomatic talks between the russian
federation and ukraine
we believe that immediate cessation of
hostilities and diligently pursuing the
path of dialogue and diplomacy is the
only way forward
it is important to undertake this
engagement keeping in mind the need to
respect the principles of the u.n
charter international law sovereignty
and territorial integrity of states i
thank you mr president
representative of india for his
statement
to the representative of china
thank you mr president
mr president
on behalf of
all the
[Music]
express our deep sadness at the passing
of a dpr of ireland ambassador jim kelly
and extend our sincere condolences to
his family
and the colleagues of the irish mission
china has stated its position on the
ukraine issue
times situation it is the shared desire
yourself under many
of the international community to
achieve a ceasefire as soon as possible
to avoid more civilian casualties and
prevent a massive humanitarian crisis
which is also what china is hoping for
direct negotiations between the parties
concerned other fundamental way to solve
the problem russia and ukraine have held
four rounds of negotiations
and also they are staying in touch with
each other with negotiations continuing
there's hope for a ceasefire and a
peaceful future
china will continue to facilitate
dialogue for peace
we support the united nations and all
parties in ramping up mediation efforts
and hope that all parties can do more
things that are conducive to promoting
peace talks rather than adding fuel to
the fire
behind the ukraine crisis is the issue
of european security
it is our hope that the united states
the european union and nato can sit down
with russia for in-depth and the
comprehensive dialogue
and explore ways and to put in place a
balanced effective and sustainable
european security architecture based on
the principle of indivisible security
so as to achieve lasting peace and
disability in europe
china's position on weapons of mass
destruction and biological security is
consistent
and clear
china stands for the complete
prohibition and the thyroid destruction
of all weapons of mass destruction
including biological and chemical
weapons
china resolutely opposes the development
possession or use of biological and
chemical weapons by any country under
any circumstances
and urges countries that haven't done so
to destroy their chemical weapons and
stockpiles as soon as possible
complying with the biological weapons
convention is the obligation of all
state parties we call for early
negotiations on the establishment of a
bwc verification regime which will help
improve the global biosecurity
activities
should trigger heightened concern and
attention of the international community
to avoid
irreparable harm
in this regard
relevant parties should take a
responsible approach
russia has further reviewed the newly
discovered relevant documents
the party concerned
should respond to questions
and offer timely and comprehensive
clarifications to remove the doubts of
the international community
we do not consider it too much to us
and on this issue
double standards should be applied
thank you mr president
i give the floor to the representative
thank you mr
[Music]
the irish delegation
for such an irreparable loss
briefing by
information
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
without restrictions or exclusions
thank you very much president
i thank the representative of mexico for
his statement
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity
is
it is an attack
[Music]
is
thank you very much president propaganda
propaganda foreign
operations
literally repeated their statements from
the 11th of march yes they
were specially moved
is
which we disseminated
uh
the questions that we asked
refusing to do so
simply because you've got nothing to say
yesterday
is
having done it
is something that the us itself has not
ukraine
ukraine and ukraine
your case is being kept in the dark
and we already provided you with facts
talked you through
ukrainian in ukraine
dangerous lethal diseases
there's no explanation for them
argument
is
revealed in the near future thank you
very much
representative of the russian federation
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
okay
yes
okay
hello
our partners are in complete denial
they won't listen to what we are saying
they won't
accept
that we are presenting facts and not
just propaganda we circulated
new new materials about the issue
among the security council members and
the general assembly
and i'm sure that you will be able to
get access to those to those documents
they are not confidential secret and you
will make you will make your own mind
what whether it's uh
whether it's propaganda
and and uh
and unsubstantiated accusations or
whether it's whether these are documents
that i was was
commenting and replying which we didn't
hear today today we heard the same the
repetition of what they said
what our partners said in the meeting of
the 11th so much they refused to accept
and to to recognize that we presented
new set of evidence of of military
biological uh programs that
that were conducted in ukraine with with
the participation of pentagon and now i
would like i would like to give the
floor to my first deputy to make a
special announcement
yes uh hello everybody i just wanted to
announce that my twitter was blocked
today and i received a message from the
client service saying that i am
violating the rules of twitter
and i am engaged in abuse and harassment
so the tweet is like this
uh that's how fake news is born we one
we warned in our statement back on seven
march that the hospital in mariupol had
has been turned into a military object
by radicals very disturbing that uean
spreads this information without
verification that was my tweet so it's
abuse and harassment according to
twitter
i will open account in telegram and you
will receive
english version
link to this account this is very
deplorable and this clearly illustrates
how much alternative view and free
free press and free information is
valued by twitter and in this country
thank you very much this is a new
interpretation of the word harassment as
well
thank you
this is
taking over
that's right
uh
all right
oh
good afternoon no it's still morning
session
uh
so we've
we've just had a council meeting
where the russians made
the same allegations that they made last
week the u.n was clear that there was no
evidence
it was nonsense then uh it's nonsense
now
and as far as we're concerned frankly
this is the disinformation of the
desperate things are clearly not going
well uh for russia uh in ukraine uh the
consequences the humanitarian
consequences are terrible
and we heard too about the wider
economic consequences for the global
economy as food prices rise and concerns
about the integrity of uh international
borders as well
and you all saw that russia withdrew
their humanitarian resolution yesterday
there was no one who was going to
support russia's invasion of ukraine
because that's what that resolution was
about
so
i think we see russia now as isolated
uh desperate
and
we are looking forward to a more
balanced discussion in the general
assembly where i think people truly
understand the humanitarian consequences
of this
invasion is slowly shifting away from
russia
so i think um president xi jinping and
president biden have just had a two-hour
conversation i haven't had a chance to
catch up on that
um i think china remains
as they've said all along very keen for
the invasion to end
for there to be dialogue they obviously
have a lot of hopes pinned on the four
rounds of dialogue so far concerned
about the humanitarian consequences
um
i'm not seeing i'm not seeing a big
shift but i china was very clear today
as well um that you know they adhered to
the chemical world biological weapons
convention and of course they
experienced chemical weapons attacks
themselves so i think
it's important
when you look at that
countries that have experienced chemical
weapons attacks or as we're in the uk
have we've seen them on our streets
you know we are i think
we find it particularly egregious when
others come with spurious claims about
these very serious sorts of issues
what do you think about russia using
security council on this matter
frankly
i think this is a perversion of the
security council's purpose first of all
there is no evidence
we heard that second of all we discussed
ukraine yesterday we talked about the
war its humanitarian impacts its
regional impacts its international
impacts
there are other items on the security
council agenda you know them well syria
yemen myanmar afghanistan
these are issues that need our attention
we do not need to be spending our time
uh on disinformation uh on a war that
russia has has started
does the uk have any intelligence that
russia is planning a chemical attack
we've
in unprecedented moves have publicized a
lot of the intelligence we have and as
have the americans
we do remain concerned uh that there
could be a false flag attack and that a
false flag attack could involve chemical
and biological uh weapons that remains a
concern but we haven't got we haven't
got published intelligence on that
yeah what's your expectation for the
humanitarian resolution in the general
assembly
uh so my hope for the humanitarian
resolution in the general assembly is
that we will see
even stronger support than we saw for
the resolution that condemned russia's
invasion so you know we had 141
countries in support of that i think as
the humanitarian consequences of
russia's invasion have become clearer
not just the immediate humanitarian
consequences for ukraine but the wider
humanitarian consequences you know bread
prices are going up fuel prices are
going up commodity prices are going up
countries whose citizens have already
been hit by covid by climate change now
they're taking another uh economic and
social hit because of russia's war so i
think we will see a lot of countries
concerned about this and also
humanitarian aid now is
thinly spread there are a lot of demands
between ukraine afghanistan syria yemen
myanmar conflict after conflict so
we could end this war and take away this
humanitarian crisis when are you
expecting a vote on the ga resolution
i think it would be really important for
us to consult the whole membership on
the ga resolution to understand how
people are approaching this question
we've got three weeks into the war three
million refugees we want to understand
how people see it but i think we need to
move fast the humanitarian situation is
deteriorating fast
so i hope we'll move uh sometime next
week
said there's no evidence of a biological
uh weapons program in ukraine but she
also said that there's no
uh capacity for them to investigate this
they don't have the capacity does that
undermine the west argument when they
say there's no evidence and point to the
u.n
no i don't i don't think it does because
the point is that the
uh cbw has is the organization that
needs to investigate those claims so
you know if there is a genuine concern
the right thing to do would be to
seal off the site
have a ceasefire seal off the site and
then allow experts in to investigate
it is not the right thing to do to bring
spurious claims to the u.n security
council which are debunked by everyone
there
could you describe what was in it what
these alleged documents are i mean what
does it look like
to be honest
it's 69 pages long
um and it does not deserve
the time to read it it's it's
disinformation of the desperate that's
how i would describe it to be honest
yeah
ukrainian refugees that they are balking
in calais in france trying to get to the
uk was is there any uh
new uh programs offered new visas
offered for these refugees that we have
also a lot of them have family members
residing in the uk
uh so we have accelerated our refugee
acceptance program in the uk
so now if you are the immediate family
member of a ukrainian in the uk you
don't need to give biometrics and that
was one of the issues originally because
there was no place to give biometrics in
calais they had to go to paris or
brussels so that's a much smoother
process we've got a process too whereby
british families can host ukrainian
refugees and i think we've already got
about 11 000 families signed up to that
in the first day we're making provision
for ukrainian children to join schools
so that they can come in as smoothly as
possible but we're also very mindful too
that uh refugees can often be
you know dispersed around and then they
become vulnerable to criminals and
traffickers so we want to make sure that
we put in place uh protection for the
refugees that was something that came up
in our discussions during the commission
on the status of women earlier this week
and i think it's a very important point
too
right thank you all very much thank you
thank you
is
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign